the Nintendo switch light is the latest
in the Nintendo switch family it is
smaller more compact smaller screen
permanently attached joy Kahn's bunch of
differences from the standard switch in
Kevin you and I got our hands on them
yep that was the first time we either of
us got to actually try the system for
ourselves and it was basically what I
expected since it was announced it was
pretty much what I expected too and I'll
be honest that is not a good thing in my
case I kind of don't see much of a
purpose for this console but you feel
differently well I'm also a little bit
torn because I agree that practically
speaking I don't need one since I
already own a switch but I still went
out and I pre-ordered one after or
hands-on time with it but I also feel
like I'm an outlier as far as switch
owners go because I use my system
primarily connected to a television
whereas you use yours mostly handheld
right yeah it's only ever docked if I'm
taking it to someone else's place or
like showing it to family or something
uh-huh
for me I'm trying to rationalize my
purchase as I'm gonna use this as a my
secondary console I take this with me on
the go and when I'm at home I'll just
play the one I already owned well let's
talk about what that secondary console
for you will actually be so as we said
it is it is smaller and lighter and
that's something you and I both
immediately noticed when we started
playing it it's a lot lighter than
original switch it's very it feels a lot
more comfortable to hold to yeah you're
not gonna get like switch thumb if you
play this a couple hours on a plane or
something I know a lot of people have
made a big deal about the d-pad and
that's absolutely great but for me I
think the best part is the analog sticks
are a little bit bigger than on the
regular toy cons yes ever so slightly
uh-huh and they feel but they don't feel
quite as rigid to move around sure yeah
so that helped a lot yeah I do agree
that that d-pad is a plus the d-pad over
the D buttons certainly is better
especially if you're playing like you
know some of those precise platformers
that you can get mine on the eShop my
bigger issue though is that those joi
cons are permanently attached and
there's been a lot of talk recently
about joi con drift and obviously if you
have that with your joy cons you can
send them in a Nintendo will repair or
replace them but in this case if you run
into that you just have to send the
entire device in and that kind of sucks
it's hard to tell if that will even be a
problem because
the joy cons have a lot of other tech
that's not included in the switch like
there's the motion controls and stuff in
that sign and that's something included
in the switch light so I don't know if
that was part of the reason that
contribute contributed to those kinds of
technical issues yeah there certainly
are fewer parts so I guess there's less
of a chance of something going wrong but
it's hard to say that's something that
will only be discovered once it's been
out in the wild for a while yeah but
that was something that we were told by
a Nintendo rep is if there is an issue
like that it's obviously case-by-case
but you know you'd probably have to send
the full device in we played a couple
different games all of which I will say
ran exactly the same as they do on a
standard switch I didn't notice with one
exception I didn't really notice any
difference yeah
the exception being Super Mario maker I
was having some weird touchscreen issues
every once in a while but they did say
that we were not playing with final
firmware so I would expect that was just
the reasoning behind it and that
wouldn't be an issue but otherwise Super
Mario maker breath of the wild Mario
Kart 8 deluxe those are the games we
played and they all played the same as
they did on a standard switch I was very
curious about breath allowed because
there are some areas in that game where
there's like very noticeable framerate
drops and we didn't get to see that
because the demo we played only started
us off in the beginning area not in the
gray plateau so I'm very curious to see
like places like the karate forest or
that framerate crops are notorious if
that's the same or not on the switch
light what we played of the games pretty
much felt the same it was lame
some games we didn't get a chance to
play that I would have loved to see
would be Super Mario Party because super
Mario Party you only play with detached
motion controlled joi cons and you can
pay our additional joi cons with the
switch light we were not able to at this
event because again it was not final
firmware but I really wanted to see that
because for me the largest detriment to
the switch light is the fact that you
cannot dock it at all there's also no
kickstand so if you're looking to play a
game like Super Mario Party you
literally just have to prop your switch
up like you know again the object uh-huh
and you know the Nintendo would not
comment on possible third-party devices
of course and I propped up the switch
light like against a little like
flowerpot or something and I said
is this what you have to do and they
said basically yeah I don't like that
that ties into basically the nature of
the systems where I was like the
original switch is very obviously meant
to be shared since has detachable
controllers you can basically give one
to anybody instead of a multiplayer
session anywhere this seems like it's
aimed as a personal device so I think
there de-emphasizing that kind of like
shared gameplay with the switch light to
some degree there de-emphasizing that
yeah because I think the idea also as it
was pitched to us was that you bring the
switch light as an additional system to
somebody's like switch Prime if you will
and then you can all sit around and play
a game but you also need to have a copy
of that game mm-hmm right but your
switch light won't be the prime know
that everybody is looking at so you know
if you're only if you are only looking
to play portable you can get that but
the biggest issue for me is that if you
ever have the desire to dock it you
can't mm-hmm if you could only choose
one switch I think the versatility of
the original is definitely much more
appealing because you could play it
however you want you could take it with
you on the go you could play it at home
you could set up a multiplayer session
anywhere whereas this is a very specific
niche that they're trying to fill with
the switch light yeah it seems to me
like the switch light is for people who
want a new 3ds whereas the original
switch was for people who are coming
from the Wii U hmm definitely for those
that might want to pick this up in
addition to the standard switch though
there is an option for transferring
saves back and forth correct yes uh-huh
you need to have a Nintendo switch
online account but you could you could
add your Nintendo account to your
secondary switch and you could download
your cloud saves play it on that console
and upload it again if you want to
continue at home or whatever so those
are the pros and joy' cons if you will
switch link yeah I've been waiting to
say that those are the pros and cons of
the switch light let us know if you
think you're gonna pick one up let us
know in the comments and for those who
are interested in picking one up they do
hit store shelves on September 20th you
can head over to GameSpot to see some of
our comparison features between the
switch light and standard switch and
stay tuned for more coverage on all the
Nintendo devices
you